previously on TV sins dad Billy
I hate complicated court hearings for
the same reason I hate old TV shows that
constant sidebars
this classroom sure does have a lot of
creepy paraphernalia by the window for
your typical high school who teaches
this class dr. Francis Neil Stein
[Applause]
Sunnydale is a small town with only one
high school so where does he go to
school and where exactly is Darla
pretending that she goes to school first
read the room buddy second does this
mean they broke into the school for this
extra curricular activity there aren't
any better places as in Sunnydale for
teens to indulge their hormone monsters
in the roof of the school this character
is so obviously the Horned douche dude
teen stereotype for the episode that
they might as well have painted lamb to
the slaughter on the back of his totally
bangin leather jacket he can always tell
it to Hollywood vampire when they pause
for a couple of seconds before attacking
to make sure the audience gets a good
look at him also love the twist of Darla
being the vampire instead of the guy but
the cheek air if anyone was there
wouldn't that have just been more food
for her
[Music]
jeez with this blaring 90s rock behind
these epilepsy inducing jump cuts I'm
actually surprised anyone put up with
the show long enough to know it was any
good Nicholas Brendon Wow when you can
pull children of the corn three urban
harvest level talent you know something
special is about to go down is this womb
that she's trying to sleep in my college
roommate because it is hella lit for a
morning when classes haven't even
started yet nightmares position shadowy
you just moved to town and it's your
first day at a new school cliche well I
certainly don't blame anyone for being
distracted by some stellar Geller I
wouldn't even have to go to physics
class to know that if this is his POV he
should have hit this handrail long
before it can cut back to him for a few
seconds and then back to her again also
when he actually takes the dive she
isn't anywhere to be seen
casual upskirting
do you have seriously you should check
it out wouldn't that be their textbook
why would they have to check anything
out couldn't come up with any better way
to get Xander in the library later to
learn Buffy's secret hey Jessie what's
what yes people used to talk like this
and yes even wear shirts that color but
what they didn't do is somehow have the
entire school immediately know in a
school this size that there was a new
student at the top of their gossip
priority list also Jessie is such a good
friend to Xander and Willow and has such
potential to be comic relief and a
helpful they'd - Buffy for many seasons
to come good thing he's not going
anywhere
it says piece of paper even if it says
sweet are we supposed to believe that he
didn't read her transcript before
putting on this cleanslate charade even
if he was planning on tearing it up to
make a point paid at least I've already
skimmed it right it wasn't that bad you
burned down the gym she winks at the
movie that preceded it even though no
one saw it and this week is wasted I
mean that gym was full of vamp act is
terrible save Buffy
not a chance Flutie didn't know you were
about to say vampires please get your
sitcom shenanigans out of my teenage
vampire action show Hey
oh you mean the one thing that would
hint at the secret she's trying to keep
from people the very item that she would
probably most care about you not finding
and also the item in her bag that is the
largest and hardest to miss that's fake
also since we find out shortly that
Buffy has zero interest in continuing
the Slayer tradition why does she even
have a stake in her purse at all why are
they sitting so close together
this popular plague led to what social
changes Steve I swear teachers and TV
shows are either completely
irresponsible with time management or
don't know how to read a clock get your
teachers done before the bell rings the
class ends at the same time every day
James Spader he needs to call me is
there anything more 90s than the version
of James Spader that is a teenage pinup
I'm not saying he wasn't good and pretty
in pink I'm just saying that most high
school girls today aren't dying to get
hit up by Raymond voice of Ultron
Reddington and yet some things never
change
anybody here good point buster why isn't
any one man in the library in the middle
of a school day as if you didn't
convenience us enough with this
newspaper sitting here just so you
didn't trust us to read what it said
without a red circle around it the only
thing I could think is that you're
building a really little fence sander
would suck at the props game on who's
lying and also offense making I don't
mean to interrupt your downward mobility
Cordelia is a terrible person but she's
maybe the greatest terrible person on a
TV show in possibly ever so that's
something I guess Jim was canceled due
to the extreme dead guy in the locker
just Jim I'm pretty sure courts location
is a decent enough reason to maybe send
everyone home for the day no you know
what with the dead guy on you know if
you need a shoulder to cry on
just to nibble on who's doing what to
who now isn't that bizarre aren't you
just going oh bobby is so freaking
adorable in there show that even my cold
black heart might have grown three sizes
watching this at least I think it was
Mary it's my first day I was afraid that
I was gonna be behind all my classes I
was a professional procrastinator in
high school for sure but even I never
managed to figure out how to be behind
in a class on the very first day to make
you a vampire they have to suck your
blood and then you have to psych their
blood it's like a whole big sucking
thing this line gave us so many sin
ideas we decided to go multiple-choice
and let you decide fun fact whole big
sucking thing is also a the name of my
new grunge tribute band be the original
title for this episode see Warner
Brothers in-house title for the DCE you
d the nickname I tried to get my college
girlfriend to call me and shouldn't
timid Whistler already know all this
isn't it the Watchers job to teach the
Slayers these things that chosen one
with the strength and scale it's a cool
legend and all but why is there only one
Slayer Sunnydale can't be the only place
that has vampires and monsters we know
la had them and in that place wherever
Lost Boys happened also what do all the
other Watchers do if there's only one
Slayer at a time yeah and I both been
there and done that and I'm moving on
about a hundred percent sure that
been-there-done-that was already a
played out frames when this came out but
I am sure my mind just collapsed in on
itself while pondering the irony of its
overuse and how many people have indeed
been there and/or done that you like
sent away for the time-life series yes
to get the free phone and the calendar
and there is the inherent risk of Weeden
icing the constant pop-culture
references are bound aged poorly in a
world where the time-life series the
phone and the calendar are now all
located on the same thing some of these
lines aren't just dated they're carbon
dated life dials didn't know a student
was in there looks like he sucks at both
of his jobs something is gonna happen to
that for me Buffy would be totally rad
at TV sense hi I'm an enormous [ __ ]
Buffy the [ __ ] shame er the thing the
salad contains one of those also common
human weight supporting horizontal bars
that the kids are always raving about
these days I know what you're thinking
don't worry I don't bite
spoiler alert he totally does as both a
character and an actor truth is I
thought you'd be taller or bigger
muscles and all that no truth is that if
this were real life you would already be
telling her exactly who you are instead
of engaging in this cloak-and-dagger
Bowl who are you let's just say I'm a
friend in pronoun games and subterfuge
there is zero reason angel couldn't tell
Buffy exactly what the low noun is other
than TV shows got a TV show even though
sprung monkey was never a huge band they
still were successful enough to not have
to resort to all a jazz clubs in
Nowheresville California also even
though you can't hear the music
trust us that there is no way this band
is singing the same song we are here
among many other clues he isn't even
holding the microphone up to his mouth
during the singing even in the close-ups
do better the 90s sucks that's willow
but if it was anyone else would she not
have saved her did someone stake out
your heart Buffy no yes
bring me something yeah hey Joss I'm not
sure discount Baltimore here it's creepy
enough oh don't you worry I've got a
line that I'm pretty sure will do the
trick
I know we're supposed to think Jessie
the idiot latorah here is a dunce and
all but I'm pretty sure that even he
could tell the difference between a
vampire bite and a hickey
Wow this is nice so when Buffy Alexander
where will it go
are we to believe Xander said this exact
[ __ ] Cemetery dink jump-scares
Vampires Suck Paul Stallone cuz we've
got a cliffhanger here's an idea
television how about just giving us
something we like so much we can't wait
to come back for the next one instead of
you know toying with our fragile heart
would you prefer a nature metaphor or a
sexual the school cut you from the team
I'm Chucky and I'm your friend to the
end yeah I don't actually date a whole
lot lately why not well this one time at
band camp reach out with your life to
hone your senses stretch out with your
feelings Lynch pin on your uniform